[موسيقى]
فصول السنه عند العرب فصلين شتاء وصيف
لايلاف قريش ايلافهم رحله الشتاء والصيف
وشهورهم مرتبطه بمواسمهم رمضان من رمز
الارض وشوال لان الناقه تشول بذيلها ربيع
ثاني ربيع جمادى جماد ثاني شتاء وكانوا
يسمون الخريف السابق للشتاء بربيع اول
ويسمون الربيع اللاحق للشتاء بربيع ثاني
وفي فتره من الفترات تلاعب العرب بشهورهم
فجعلوا ربيع اول بجانب ربيع ثاني وهذا
التلاعب من اجل مصالحهم شخصيه ويسمى
بالنسيء ومعمجي الاسلام ابطل عليهم هذا
انما النسيء زياده في الكفر يظل به الذين
كفروا يحلونه عاما ويحرمونه عاما ليواطئوا
عده ماء
حرم الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والشهور العربيه قمريه الحركه هو موسميه
التسميه والفارق بين الشمسيه والقمريه
يجعلونها اعيادا لهم خارج نسق التقويم ومع
تحريم النسيء خرجت الشهور عن مسمياتها
الفصليه مثل رمضان يجينا بالصيف ويجينا
بشته ويجينا بالخريف ويجينا بالربيع برق
الربيع لنا برون قمائه فانظر لروعه ارضه
وسمائه والطير مثل المحسنات صوادح مثل
المغني شاديا
بغنائه
[موسيقى]